you know their lovemaking with a cardi
places like that the places like I'd
never been to Canyon de Chelly and so I
went there and I
I found the guy that was a Native
American man Navajo who was willing to
take me in his Jeep to the canyon
wonderful wonderful stories he told I'd
never been to four corners Arizona so we
we drove up there and and I mean that
I learned that four corners Arizona is
actually not in geographical four
corners they missed it by about
something like 2,000 feet or something
well it's just things like that it was
just a wonderful adventure
and it evolved into lots of storytelling
stories that people would tell me and
then and then my own research and
stories I'd find out about places around
Arizona I I think it's more about our
connections who we are is Arizona it's
that it's not like you know we're not
it's
you know that we're not like with the
media portrays that that we are a
diverse multicultural people who are
just kind of you know thrown together in
an extraordinary environment mostly the
Sonoran Desert and you know it's it's
nothing it's not like you go out into
the desert and you find headless people
you know and this is what everybody
hears about you know this is an amazing
place it has a rich culture I want
people to come out here and experience
it and see that it's not like what a lot
of media portray c-span is in the desert
city of Tucson Arizona to learn more
about its literary scene up next we
speak with author Samara Clarke on her
book about independent voters
independent voters are important in some
ways and seemingly fairly
inconsequential in other ways turns out
that independent voters by and large do
support one of the two major parties
about 93% of independents will tell
pollsters when asked that they actually
do prefer either the Democrats or the
Republicans and they tend to vote very
consistently for those parties so
independents who lean toward the
Democrats almost always vote for the
Democrats and independents who lean
toward the Republicans almost always
vote for the Republicans so if we look
at it from a voting perspective at first
it seems as though independents aren't
really that important and that's sort of
what political sciences have thought
about them for several decades now but
my co-author Jana critic of and I
decided to take another look at
independence and start to look at how
they act when it comes to politics
whether they're engaged with politics
what we found is that independents are
much less likely to participate in
certain political activities for example
putting up a yard sign on your lawn or
wearing a sticker or even telling your
friends who you're gonna vote for
independence tend to want to appear
independent so they don't do those kinds
of things so when it comes actually
participating in the grassroots
activities they're really important
because they're not participating in
those kinds of things we've seen
independents steadily increase over the
past half-century right now both Pugh
and Gallup are seeing more independence
than they ever have before so we're
really at an all-time high we now have
more Americans who identify as
independent than either of the other two
parties so it is the most common most
frequent identification in polls about
40% of Americans say that they are
independent and then of course the
remaining 60% is spread split about
evenly between Democrats and Republicans
so why this has been happening steadily
over time there's a lot of theories as
to what has caused the increase the one
that Jana and I really focus on is the
role of negativity in politics as we
have seen politics become more negative
in you know in the United States the
social desirability bias against
Democrats and Republicans is increasing
Americans don't want to be associated
with fighting and bickering and personal
attacks I think there's a big
misconception among media in particular
that independent voters are swing voters
and they're not independent
voters aren't swing voters and they're
not even ideologically moderate many of
them are very conservative or very
liberal so it's not necessarily true
that independents are this voting bloc
that's up for grabs so the question that
really motivated this book was why would
someone say they're independent when in
fact they're actually voting for a party
that's really what drove Jana and I to
to start this research in the first
place what we found is there's this real
social desirability bias against
partisans so there's almost a consensus
among the American public now that
independents are just more appealing
than Democrats or Republicans we did it
over a dozen experiments and national
surveys we found that people think
independents are more physically
attractive they're more trustworthy
they're more likable they generally
prefer to live around independence to
work with independence so if you're
trying to make the best impression on
other people the best way to do that is
to say you're independent even among
strong Republicans and strong Democrats
so people who really prefer their party
they will also admit that independents
are more the aspirational ideal that's
what people should really strive to be
people really do talk about this sort of
higher ground you know they'll say I'm
above all the fighting I'm above all the
bickering I don't want to support the
lesser of two evils so people do see
independence as the sort of more noble
choice among these kind of- the sort of
the negative stereotypes that we have
with democrats and republicans we also
asked people as independents what
message would they give to the president
and they want compromise they want
people to work together they want
bipartisanship that's what they say
now we also tested whether that's
actually true with a series of
experiments in which we asked both
Democrats Republicans and independents
how they would actually react if their
own representative compromised their own
values for the sake of bipartisanship we
find as all groups independents included
would be very upset if that happened so
even for independents the word
compromise for them tends to mean the
other party is compromising they don't
really see compromise as something that
their own party should be doing I think
one of the biggest mystery is right now
is you know if
there are so many independents if the
independent label is seen as so socially
desirable why do we not have a
successful third party you know I think
they're the probably the biggest reason
for that well you know there's some
structural reasons having to do with the
Democratic National Committee and the
Republican National Committee who do
have a lot of power in American politics
but you know Americans are also very
tied to their party label independence
although they may not vote they may not
identify with a particular party have
spent their lives voting for the same
party over and over again for the most
part and it really is hard to break away
Americans rely very heavily on
electability when they're looking at
candidates one of the biggest challenges
that I can't fit like Gary Johnson for
example has to face is this electability
factor it can he actually win people
don't want to feel like they're throwing
their vote away on a candidate who's not
actually gonna win that was Bernie
Sanders biggest hurdle as well and I
think for the large part he managed to
overcome it but I think you know that's
always gonna keep a third party Dam in
the United States I think the rise of
Donald Trump and also the success that
Bernie Sanders has is actually largely a
function of the appeal of Independence
and Bernie Sanders is an independent I
mean that he's officially independent
Donald Trump really has no real
connection to either of the two parties
he's his past is connected to Democrats
and it was Republican so I think both of
those candidates really allowed
Americans to support a candidate that
was not squarely in either party so
Donald Trump I think can can thank
independence largely for his rise
because he was seen as non partisan in a
lot of ways Barack Obama had you know he
really enjoyed the same benefit he cast
his campaign a sort of this post
partisan campaign McCain and Palin tried
to do the same thing saying there's a
rogue maverick so I think a lot of
candidates have seen the benefit of
identifying as independent or at least
I'm trying to convey this independent
message now that Donald Trump is the
Republican candidate he is in the
establishment there's nothing he knew
about now he's sort of a lost that that
allure I think the most important
implicit
shishun of the book is that this
dissatisfaction with the parties is
really consequential what it means is
that more and more Americans are gonna
withdraw from participating in politics
and that's gonna leave our political
system in the hands of just a very few
number of people who might be a little
more extreme than the average voter
so as Democrats and Republicans become
less socially desirable more Americans
are gonna disassociate themselves with
it and they're not gonna go knocking
door-to-door they're not going to talk
about politics at work and they're not
gonna try to convince their friends to
vote for a particular candidate and
those lower levels of engagement are
really problematic because it really
leaves candidates election and even did
about our democracy itself in the hands
of sort of those who don't necessarily
represent the rest of us
c-span is in Tucson to learn more about
the city's literary scene up next we
speak with author Thomas Sheridan who
goes in-depth about the events that
shaped the Grand Canyon State there are
a number of misconceptions about Arizona
in its history and one of them is that
all the Mexicans here are immigrants
from Mexico but like the the Auton
people you know the Tohono O'odham
people say we didn't cross the border
the border crossed us and long before
Arizona ever became a part of the United
States it was a part of first Spanish
and then later Mexican Sonora and so
Tucson was really the northernmost the
northernmost community in in the
province and later the state of Sonora
so there are families here Mexican
families here who've been here seven
eight generations including some that
were with the original group of Presidio
soldiers who came up here in 1776 and
actually founded the community of Tucson
the US has been has always been a very
racialized Society and you know back
east we tend to think of black/white
relations but as as this area became a
part of the United States after the
Mexican War and then with the Gadsden
Purchase in 1854 all of a sudden white
Americans had to deal with Mexican
people and you know they in many read
well the Mexican they didn't consider
the Mexicans to be white so they thought
that they were inferior to them they
weren't didn't quite know where to place
them in the kind of racial hierarchy
that existed in the country at that time
you know they weren't slaves they
weren't African or African American but
they definitely were
not white and you know sometimes they
were referred to for example as a race
of Mongols you know this sort of mixture
between native people and and Europeans
like the Spaniards so almost from the
very beginning there were these patterns
of where the you know the Anglo
newcomers tried to dominate the Mexicans
who were already living here now it
wasn't quite as bad as it was in parts
of California in Texas primarily because
from the 1850s until the 1880s there
weren't a lot of Anglo settlers here you
know Arizona was considered this kind of
dry desolate Apache infested hellhole on
the way to California so a lot of you
know there a lot of people weren't
attracted to settle here and in fact for
about a twenty year period most of the
Anglo newcomers were adult males very
few Anglo women came in and so many of
those those males married Mexican women
and into Mexican families and also
started businesses with either with
Mexicans who had been here for a long
time or also with Mexican entrepreneurs
who were moving into the area from
Sonora or Chihuahua so there for about a
20 year period there was this kind of
biracial bilingual society where you
know in one sense Mexicans assimilated
the Anglos rather than vice-versa but
all that changed very quickly once the
you know the Southern Pacific Railroad
came in because all of a sudden you know
you could bring in outside goods more
settlers arrived you know to ranch or to
mine more Anglo women arrived and so
Tucson very quickly became a segregated
come
unity with Mexican families being pushed
out of the old Presidio downtown area by
Anglo businessman and they moved either
south or west and then as more Anglo
settlers moved in they meant move north
and east
so this de-facto ethnic racial
segregation really took hold here
even though Mexicans remained a majority
of Toussaint's population until 1910
it's as if they had disappeared from the
face of the earth in the newspapers
beginning in the 1870s no coverage of
Mexican businessmen no coverage of
Mexican artists the only thing you might
get was two Mexicans knife got in into a
knife fight in barrio libre on Saturday
night and that really persisted well it
still persists in many you know in many
many respects it's interesting you know
I wrote history of Arizona that the
first edition came out in 1995 the
second edition came out in 2012 you know
in honor of the centennial of Arizona
statehood and what I saw then was when
Arizona became became a state there was
this widespread anti-mexican movement
interestingly enough back then it came
from the left rather than the right and
it was Anglo Anglo Irish miners who and
union organizers who wanted to keep
Mexicans out of the mines because those
were the best paying jobs and they tried
to get these anti Mexican measures in
the US Constitution and then the Arizona
Constitution and later when those were
either turned down they tried to pass
similar measures
in the legislature and then when I went
back to revise my my history I realized
that we were living through a similar
period of anti-mexican sentiment only
this time it was coming more from the
right beginning in the late 1980s with
the English only movement a series of
laws designed to you know make English
the official language of Arizona and
mandate that only English would be
spoken in you know government agencies
and public facilities and then with you
know explosive surge in immigration
Mexican immigration in the 1990s and the
early 2000s the sort of anti Mexican
anti-immigrant hysteria
you know rows and rows and rows and we
got bills like SB 1070 which you know
garnered national attention which you
know tried to force municipal police
departments to request immigration
papers every time they stopped you know
a Mexican looking person you know for a
traffic violation or whatever and you
know we were going through another
period of anti Mexican political
agitation that you know was was pretty
successful in the sense that you know
many of those anti Mexican measures were
passed into law I think that
anti-mexican sentiment was really fueled
by you know Anglo newcomers to Arizona
who had many of them retired who moved
into the state in the 1980s 1990s who
had no understanding of Arizona history
no understanding of Arizona
Mexico's you know deep ties with one
another ties of Commerce ties of family
ties of culture ties of history and
looked at at all Mexican people
including US citizens as these you know
kind of brown immigrant hordes from the
south who were threatening us
sovereignty and you know I think which
it was a complete misreading of Arizona
history and you know who who we are in
Arizona when Arizona was making that
transition from being a frontier to
being a part of the United States in
agriculture on the railroads even in the
the logging industry the majority of the
workers were Mexican and Mexican
American and that's true for all of the
western United States
you know the western US would not have
been built without Mexican labor so I
would like them to you know get a you
know the deeper richer sense of the rule
that Mexican people have played in the
history of the state and in the history
of the country
c-span is in Tucson Arizona to learn
about its history and literary culture
while here we took a driving tour with
Tucson weekly smari Harris to learn more
about the city's unique heritage
okay so Tucson Arizona if someone has
never been to Tucson what is sort of the
quintessential thing about the city that
people should know well we're no longer
cowboys and Indians kind of city that's
for sure so if people are thinking about
John Wayne and western movies that's
something that they definitely need to
put out in their of their mind we're
close to the border and so that border
politics is really important to a lot of
people in Tucson we have the state
that's very conservative politically but
Tucson kind of takes pride in being the
button-pusher City the city that's a
little bit more progressive than you
know Phoenix and one of the great things
that two suns had for ages and then go
through and come up Congress right here
is that we've had always had a really
burgeoning music scene I mean we've
always had a great music scene since
since the 80s when I was going to school
here the Rialto right here club Congress
right here it's an important this is
right here's a very important part of of
that music scene we you know Rialto is
constantly listed as being one of the
best music venues in the country
Congress also hosts a lot of national
acts but it's also a really strong place
for local local performances so let's
leave downtown we're gonna head south so
you talked again about being close to
the border so right the Mexican heritage
is alive here in a lot of aspects and
one of those is food right right one of
those is food but I think we were
talking earlier about the whole UNESCO
World Heritage selection this isn't just
about Mexican food for us it's also goes
back to our you know the fact that we
have been and
habited town pueblo an inhabited area
for going back thousands you know
several thousand years most inhabited
town in the country supposedly I'm sure
something we could have an arguing with
other people about but that's what we we
embrace so you recently were given that
distinction what is it again nesco World
Heritage Site for for gastronomy so it's
about a food heritage starts our food
hair it's not just Mexican food which
really in the skin things hasn't been
here that long but it's also about our
connection with our tribal our tribes
you know we have two tribes here Tohono
o odham and the yaki nation both are
important parts of our community here
and the Tohono o odham for instance you
know and the yaki but the tono and
really have persevered in part of the
place we're going to be heading to is
the sound of your mission where the
reservation is and there's a co-op farm
the San Santa veer district tone Odom a
co-op farm where they grow heritage
crops like temporary beans and different
kinds of wheats and grains and melons
that are only have only have a history
of growing here in the desert so you see
over here the mission oh my gosh so so
see how beautiful it is you can see from
here you can see it from the top of
tumamoc and a mountain and it's called
the white dove you can see why beautiful
I mean it kind of takes your breath away
from the smooth even this far away I
mean you see this this landscape that
you know you have the greenery the trees
the the desert and then it just kind of
rises yeah yeah that's stunning it is
pretty I know what your are we talking
how long has this been here 1600s I
can't off the top of my head so it's
pretty much everything that you see
every other grand building your goes
downtown
yeah absolutely now this is hold a
special place for the tribe it is on
tribal lands so how does that fit
together it does I mean this has always
been part of the culture here and and
the community here it's important part
of the community there's it's important
part for the Catholic community of
Tucson as well and then it's also
important part for
who just love our our tradition and our
history and our culture this yet this is
definitely one of those special places
and from my family's beyond its history
we you know we have a having a
great-uncle
Edie at at us who was part of mohini's
brother were part of a group that we're
trying to figure out how to maintain the
stucco than the integrity of the outside
of building when they were doing a
remodel this is remodel has been going
on or renovations been going on
different steps for many years and they
ended up being prickly pear juice was
the added ingredient really what a
call-out yeah it was one of those things
that oh yeah what could they have used
back then prickly pear juice you know
inside or different frescoes that have
been there were painted this was built
by the Indians of the the totem in the
ends of that time of quino's time when
he was here there was only the priests
the other priests you know and these and
Indians so you're you look on the on the
walls it's hysterical there's supposedly
women but they they kind of look like
trees frankly there's some interesting
details that are they're kind of fun too
to look at that is that a stunning and
it's amazing that the craftsmanship of
so many years ago is still standing
today a sort of a testament again to the
hair did you - sod right well you don't
before nesco before Janis Wilder before
all these other people were talking
about there was this that's incredible
okay so we've talked about the Mexican
heritage the native heritage this
gorgeous mission what next what's
happening parents your son now well
let's go let's go up to a place that's
really special to me
it's called tumamoc we've it has the
longest ongoing continuous research in
the country goes back in the early 1900
sending 1903 now what kind of research
are we so we're talking about ecology
environmental research desert ecology
it's got one of the oldest ongoing
Saguaro
research that's done and it's it's it's
location close to in urban areas what's
also become increasingly important
because you now it's like how is how is
our ecology in in or urban in urban
environments and how how things
mentioned how is how are these so I was
doing on the suicides past hundred years
why is it so important before that
desert research to occur here well you
know we you know we talk about our love
for this area and how we want we want
you know this this place to be loved and
protected and it's the the the
environment is really important to us
and we know that with climate change
things are changing there's no doubt
saguaro some areas or ours are being
looked at a little more closely because
their health is in peril we it's more
important than ever that that station be
there and that research occur but it's
also important for it and its connection
to the community for people to
understand that that research is
happening for people to understand that
that means I recall our back door
ecology our city ecology or city
environment is is just as important as
as anyplace else
when I tuned into it on the weekends
usually its authors sharing up their new
releases watching the nonfiction authors
on book TV is the best television for
serious readers on c-span they can have
a longer conversation and delve into
their subject book TV weekends they
bring you author after author after
author that spotlight the work of
fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly author interview program Columbia
University Law Professor Tim woo
explained the ways society has been
affected by advertising former goldman
sachs vice-president julissa r say
described her experience as an
undocumented immigrant and Temple
University professor Sarah goldrich
Rebbe explained possible solutions to
rising college tuition costs in the
coming weeks on afterwards Harvard
University economist George Boras will
talk about his research on the impact of
immigration on the US economy Gary Young
editor at large for The Guardian will
discuss his investigation of gun
violence in America also coming up
Washington Post columnist Sebastian
Mallaby will talk about the career of
former Federal Reserve Chairman Alan
Greenspan and this weekend Bain Capital
co-founder Edward Connard argues that
income inequality contributes to
economic growth those synergies were
created gradually over time through
successful risk-taking that bubbled up
from a much larger pool of failed
risk-taking so I think we always have
the option of we can tax and distribute
more in the short run but we slow down
the growth and in the long run look at
the difference between the growth rate
of the United States and Europe look at
the difference between the income levels
of the United States and Japan there
they get bigger and bigger and bigger
and the differences get bigger and
bigger and the ability for those
countries to catch up now that they've
fallen behind it's unlikely that they
can catch up unless we have a major
shift in technology say to biology or or
something else besides really I think
we're heading towards consciousness with
computers and the internet and we have a
a big advantage that maybe we can't
sustain forever but we certainly have a
big competitive advantage today
afterwards airs on book TV every
Saturday at 10:00 p.m. and Sunday at
9:00 p.m. Eastern you can watch all
previous afterwards programs on our web
site book TV org
and you're watching book TV on c-span -
its television for serious readers now
here's a look at our primetime lineup
for tonight we'll kick off the evening
in just a few minutes with the Cato
Institute Johan Norberg he argues that
despite an endless stream of bad news
there should be great optimism for the
future at 9:00 p.m. this evening Nancy
Malkiel who's the former dean of the
college at Princeton University reports
on the decision for many colleges and
universities to go co-ed during the
1960s then at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time on
booked TVs afterwards program Bain
Capital founding partner Edward Connard
discusses income inequality with Greg
Mankiw who's the former chair of the
Council of Economic Advisors during the
Bush administration and we wrap up book
TV in primetime at 11:00 p.m.
Chuck Collins will be the author he's
the great-grandson of meat packer Oscar
Mayer and he talks about wealth
inequality and his decision to give away
much of his inheritance now that all
happens tonight on c-span 2's book TV
but first up here's Johan Norberg of the
Cato Institute
good morning and welcome to the cato
institute my name is Maryann 2p I'm a
senior policy analyst here at Cato and
also editor of human progress which is
an educational website that tries to put
together as many statistics about human
well-being as possible in order to
present to our users and to the general
public the more real picture of the
world then then the headlines would
suggest speaking about the headlines
it is perhaps an understatement to say
that we'll live in an era of great
pessimism this pessimism is not
distributed evenly across the world but
it is felt very acutely in many Western
democracies including ours here in the
United States some three quarters of
Americans believe that the United States
is going in the wrong direction
and the choices that the electorate will
be presented with come November
exaggerate rather than soothe the
national feeling of impending doom
Americans feel poorer even though our
GDP per capita has never been higher we
feel less safe even though international
conflicts have almost disappeared and
deaths from terrorism are extremely rare
overall life expectancy is at an
all-time high and progress is being made
in curing cancer Alzheimer's and
hiv/aids globally the speed of
improvements in human wellbeing is
staggering fueled by its embrace of
capitalism and globalization Chinese per
capita income has grown by an incredible
900 percent in my lifetime during that
time Indian life expectancy
rose by a third from 52 years to 68
years and that's three billion people
right there yet for all the good news
gloom is pervasive and pessimism about
the future is widespread the gap between
the perception and the reality of daily
daily life is not new in 1830 British
historian thomas babington macaulay
observed quote we cannot absolutely
prove that those are in error who tell
us that society has reached a turning
point that we have seen our best days
but so said all before us and with just
as much apparent reason on what
principle is it that we see nothing but
improvement behind us yet we expect
nothing but deterioration ahead of us
unquote luckily a small but merry group
of optimists has been trying to cheer us
up they include the late the late Julian
Simon indoor Golani of the Cato
Institute Charles Kenny beyond Lomborg
Deirdre McCloskey Steven Pinker Matt
Ridley max max Rosser hence rustling as
well as our two speakers today Johan
Norberg is a senior fellow at the Cato
Institute and the writer who focuses on
globalization entrepreneurship and
individual liberty Norberg is the author
and editor of several books books
exploring libertarian ideas including
financial Fiasco how America's
infatuation with home ownership and easy
money created the economic crisis his
book in defense of global capitalism
which was originally published in 2001
was since then published in 20 different
countries
prior to joining Cato norburg was a head
of political ideas at Tim bro a Swedish
free market think-tank between 2003 and
2005 he then served as a
senior fellow at the brussels-based
center for new Europe and that was in
2006 no burg received his master's
degree from Stockholm University in the
history of ideas and today he's here to
present his new book and talk about it
the new book is called progress
10 reasons to look forward to the future
and with a hearty commendation of this
book please help me welcome Johan
Norberg
[Applause]
thank you very much Marian and thank you
so much for keeping human progress org
my daily dose of sanity when I otherwise
just read the news and get the
impression that the world is falling
apart I've used that a lot when I wrote
this book I'm also honored to have Ron
Bailey joining me here on the stage one
of my intellectual heroes who have
written many books outlining the
progress that mankind has done he
explained to me once and I think he
writes about this in his latest book
that when he wrote a book on human
progress his agent said that look this
book will make us some money but if you
had written a book outlining why the
world will end very shortly then we
would both be rich men so why do you
write a book on progress with all the
trouble in the world why do I write a
book about reasons to look forward to
the future well for three reasons
one because it happened and it's one of
the most important things that ever
happened to mankind - because no one
believes me when I tell them that that's
the case and three it's dangerous that
they don't because pessimism is a
powerful political force let me start
with what happened and how it happened
this is the
GDP per capita around the world over the
last 2000 years where we can see that
not much happened until the early 19th
century when suddenly we saw an
explosion of wealth starting in the
Western world but then spreading around
the world in the era of globalization
and in 1820 you notice that there wasn't
much wealth around in the world even in
the rich the richest countries suffered
from desperate poverty if we had shared
all the wealth that existed in the world
in 1820 the average person around the
world would have a GDP per capita lower
than the GDP per capita of Mozambique
today so everything happened afterwards
and that's everything that made our life
here today possible it made this
possible the eradication of poverty
around the world over the last 200 years
200 years ago 90% of the world
population lived in extreme poverty
around less than $2 per day of
consumption adjusted for inflation
purchasing powers and today it's less
than 10% since 1990 this has accelerated
in 1990 37 % of the world population
lived in extreme poverty today it's
around 9% which means that for the first
time in world history the absolute
number of poor people has been reduced
as well and for the first time since the
eighteen hundreds we have seen fewer
people living we have fewer people live
in extreme poverty today than in 1800
that might not sound like much progress
but if you consider the growth in world
population it is tremendous progress in
1800 there were only 60 million people
around the world who did not live in
extreme poverty today 6.5 billion people
do and this is as I pointed out
accelerated since 1990 over that period
world population grew by around 2
billion people and
yet the absolute number of extremely
poor was reduced by 1.25 billion people
which means that every minute that we
talk about this subject another 100
people rise out of extreme poverty
mankind has never ever seen that kind of
progress and here is another graph that
summarizes the changes that have taken
place over the last few hundred years
life expectancy if that continues to
climb it means we've done something
right when it comes to wealth health
nutrition and lifestyle in 1900 the
average life expectancy around the world
was 31 years today
amazingly it's 71 years in the year 1800
no country nowhere had a life expectancy
higher than 40 years today there's not a
single country anywhere with a life
expectancy shorter than 40 percent and
this continues every day around the
world not for every group there are
always laggards but the rising life
expectancy continues nonetheless the
country with bethe best practice has
increased life expectancy by 3 months
every year for the last 140 years and
that continues we can celebrate every
birthday - by just approaching death by
nine months rather than one year and
this because of the reduction in child
mortality in many sub-saharan African
countries this has resulted in the
fastest progress in life expectancy
we've ever seen some countries like
Botswana and Rwanda increased life
expectancy by 10 years over the last 10
years which means that collectively you
can say that every person got 10 years
older but none of them approached death
by a single day and those new years are
also good years as a review of the
literature pointed out in Lancet
recently present evidence suggests that
people are not only living
longer than they did previously but also
they are living longer with less
disability and fewer functional
limitations so all those data are quite
impressive over the last 200 years but
it's even more impressive in the last
few years in the last 25 years this is a
summary graph over hunger poverty
illiteracy child mortality and the six
leading pollutants in Britain I used
Britain because the book was originally
published there but if we had had the
United States there it would have been
even more impressive and you can see
that all those things indexed so that
100 percent is the level in in 1990 have
been more aft or more than half over
these few years when it comes to wealth
we've created as much increase in GDP
per capita in the last 30 years as we
did in the 30,000 years before and yet
this does not come across as good news
to everybody in the Western world in
Western Europe and in the United States
a lot of people look at these data and
think that they are the losses that
they've lost out at least relatively
they are the losses of globalization
because progress has not been as fast
here as it's been in many other
countries around the world something
strange happened in the years since I
wrote the Cato book in defense of global
capitalism in 2003 and this recent book
because that time I I kind of wrote the
same book about human progress I've got
to confess that and how free markets and
free trade could benefit us all at that
time the opponents were the leftists in
the anti-globalization movement who
thought that free trade multinational
companies investments free-market
capitalism that might benefit us the
rich in the richest countries but there
would be losers poor people in poor
countries who would be exploited who
would see their life living stand
deteriorate I think it's fair to say
that these 13 years that have passed
have proved them wrong the development
in countries like Vietnam India China
and many many other countries that have
integrated into the global economy has
proved that it was a tremendous boom to
their living standards to their wealth
and a lot of people accept that but then
they say oh we were wrong in thinking
that they would lose out from capital
international capitalism they won big
time which must mean that we are the
losers
in rich countries because they still
believe in the 0 sum game the idea that
the economy and the world economy is a
zero-sum game in which people can only
gain if someone else loses out a kind of
pre Adam Smithian view of the economy
where trade does not benefit both
parties to the agreement and that's a
very dangerous assumption that leads to
a search for scapegoats this is a graph
that you might have seen this is the
so-called elephant
graph of the increase in average per
capita in household income of each
percentile group around the world all
over the world between 1988 and 2008
it's a former World Bank economist
Branko Milanovic who who assembled the
date and created this graph and it looks
a bit like an elephant because you can
see that the poor in the world most of
the poor have increased their income
strim attica Li over those 20 years by
some 40 to 80 percent and you also see
that the elephant's trunk is raised
because the super rich in the world the
1% of the 2%
they've also benefited tremendously but
look at what became known as the Western
middle class on the lower middle classes
in Europe and the United States around
the 80 and 98th percentile
people who didn't see any kind of income
growth over those 20 years this was the
graph that was presented around the
world as the graph that explains
globalization and the losses of
globalization's those who turn to
leftists and rightists populist s' those
who vote for Donald Trump or Bernie
Sanders and it is a powerful graph but
it's wrong as being presented recently
in a a very heroic work by the
resolution foundation this is a
combination of various data sources
people move through these percentiles
countries shift population growth in
some places but not in others mean that
the 18th to 19th percentile is not the
same people it's not the Western middle
classes yes that's true that it used to
be the case in 1988 that that that was
the Western middle class but not anymore
first for three reasons first of all the
countries in this this data shifted
dramatically there wasn't data for a lot
of these countries in 1988 but there
were in 2008 big poor countries like
Vietnam Congo Russia were added since
then so and that lowers the income
growth in every percentile basically
because you add poor countries so you
can see that the old elephant graph is
the blue one the yellow dotted line is
the one if we keep the countries in the
sample constant over these years then
you can see that the Western middle
class so to speak increased their income
growth from 0% to 10%
but there's another graph there as well
the red line and the red line
compensates for something else that
population growth was bigger in poor
countries than in rich countries which
means that a lot of people that they
took a larger part of every percentile
and it means that they especially in
population growth in Asia pushed the
Western middle class from the lower
percentiles into the higher ones so what
used to be the 18th and 19th percentile
of Western middle class people were
replaced by the richest people in China
and they are still poorer some 60% as
rich as the Western middle classes which
means that it looks like poverty that
like income growth is is coming down in
those areas as well but that's more an
illusion that comes from population
growth so if you keep population growth
if you pretend that the population is
stable over these years the elephant
graph shifts to the red line instead and
then it's not the zero percent income
growth it's not a ten percent income
growth it's a twenty five percent income
growth for the 18th to 19th 90th
percentile but then something else
interesting happens when you look at the
raw data there are a few countries that
really stagnated or even saw a reduction
in incomes over those 20 years Japan and
X communist countries like Bulgaria and
they've all they made more progress
after 2008 but that's not relevant for
this graph because it only goes to 2008
so that's true that did happen but that
is not where the Western middle classes
live they don't live in Eastern Europe
they do not live in Japan so if you're
just for that as well and look at a new
version of the elephant graph you can
see that a constant population with
constant countries except and you except
Japan and X communist countries we have
the red line instead where the
percentile that we talk about is the
Western middle class increase their
incomes by some 40% over these 20 years
we don't need to bother about the the
yellow one so there has been an increase
in incomes in Western countries for
Western middle classes as well
but I also have to point out that that's
not the most important thing the most
important thing is not what you have in
your wallet but what you can buy for it
the kind of purchasing power the kind of
technology of that is at your disposal
it's much more than income and we've
seen progress in many other areas
cleaner air since since the 1970s when I
was born we've seen more than you you've
more than half the leading pollutants
and that affects your lungs your forests
your rivers your seas oh you've haft
crime rates homicide rate in the US has
been cut in half since 1980 including
better technology from better drugs to
the Internet and another 10 years of
life expectancy if that's the losers of
globalization then we need to reconsider
what we mean by a loser what is progress
what does it mean to me it means that we
can do more things today than we could
before we know more things were able to
create more things and as the great
thinker Robert Heinlein put it progress
is not made by early rises it's made by
lazy men looking for easier ways to do
things basically we do more things with
the resources that are at our disposal
we can solve more problems we can deal
with more of our problems we can satisfy
more of our ambitions and more of our
demands and we do that by exploring and
thereby finding new better knowledge
about how the world works and not just
exploring but also experimenting with
those ideas producing new innovations
and technology artificial fertilizers
better crops new machines that make us
more productive container shipping that
makes it possible to exchange all those
things but it's not just that we explore
an experiment but it's also that we
exchange the results of this with trade
communication movement over borders
which means that we can use knowledge
that we do not have ourselves so
exploration experimentation annex
change which means that we need freedom
freedom to think freedom to be
innovative freedom to implement your
ideas and experiment and freedom to
trade across borders
we need liberty and therefore it's no
coincidence that this began to happen in
northern Europe in Western Europe and in
Northern America and it began to happen
in China India Vietnam after they began
to open up their economies more people
than ever can now contribute to this
progress because they have access to
more knowledge than ever and they are
freer than ever to experiment with those
ideas and exchange this with other
people as Julian Simon the grand old man
of development optimism put it the human
being the human brain is the ultimate
resource and that's also something
that's reproducible the human brain is
actually pleasantly reproducible at
least it's a beautiful thing when it
happens between consenting adults but
the problem is that almost no one
believes this let's go back to this
graph about human progress since 1990 in
all those areas in all those dimensions
I posted this on Twitter a couple of a
few weeks ago to tell the world about
look this is the world in one graph
while we've complaining this is what
happened to the world and one of the
first responses I got was this from a
British woman who retweeted this and
said oh my god this is startling
graphics confirming my general hell in a
handcart feeling in other words she read
the graph upside down so she thought
that poverty has double that child
mortality had doubled that pollution
that illiteracy had doubled around the
world and I asked her how did you get
that impression and she responded oh I
do pay close attention to the news and
to the media I follow what happens in
the world I read about the floods the
war the famines that go on in the world
and that's true that is something that
happens but it also means that she
misses out the great trends around the
world and so as Miriam put it the all
the gallops show that people are almost
by nature pessimists six percent of
Americans think that the world on the
whole is becoming a better place
more people believing ghosts and UFOs
than believe in progress earth where the
global poverty had halfed doubled or
remain the same in the past 20 years
only five percent of Americans said that
it had haft
and actually it had more than half most
thought that it was stable or had
doubled by guessing randomly a shrimp
and sea would pick the right answer out
of three choices far more often which
means that this is not ignorant you
cannot call it ignorance if you can't
beat a random choice we must have
inaccurate assumptions about the world
based on some misleading or outdated
information about the world and as this
British woman most people get it from
the media from the headlines from the
breaking news I picked this illustration
it's from a Sweden's biggest newspaper I
love that headline because it says total
chaos everywhere
and there were some bad weather and some
traffic stops and thousands of people
were stuck at the airports because of
this total chaos everywhere because an
airplane accident is news 40 million
flights taking off landing safely every
year is not news the fact that we have
seen since the 1970 an increase in the
number of passengers tenfold and yet the
number of accidents and fatalities has
halfed that's not news that's statistics
that's something that we don't care
about and in a way that's a good thing
if there were news about plans late
flights landing safely it would mean
that it was a strange occurrence
it would have been news but the problem
is that when we only hear about those
accidents those disasters then we think
that this is the only
thing that goes on in the world it was
made the news recently that tens of
thousands of people in northern Nigeria
are now threatened by chronic
undernourishment and famine and that's
correct that happens we need to know
about that but I have never read a story
about the fact that 8 million Nigerians
were liberated for chronic
undernourishment over the last 25 years
because that's not the kind of shocking
instantaneous horrific thing that makes
the news it's not really about the media
it's not the journalists fault that bad
news sells because when the media is not
there we actually invent stories rumors
that are even worse so it seems like we
are to blame and the readers and that's
what all the journalists tell me as well
when I ask them about this it doesn't
sell good news we need something
dramatic and shocking to give to to sell
the news and I think this is because
we're genetically predisposed to pay
more attention to bad things bad is
stronger than good because the bad